so when molly was a little girl
she's with her dad
her mom in the car
her two sisters
and her cousin and the most horrible
thing happened dad was loaded he was
drunk driving the car accident happens
one of your sisters dies you lost your
little sister and your older cousin and
your mom dies basically the last thing
you heard her say is where are my girls
and yet dad never apologized for it i
will say this howard he he never really
wavered from his story till his death he
was i did i did not blame him because he
was like no no because we would talk
about it he was like i asked your mom to
drive i asked fran to drive it was an
all-day party he had been drinking
took a nap and then left much later and
i guess my mom was like no you can drive
and this is
1968. this is 50 years ago it's before
mothers against drunk driving friends
don't let friends drive drunk we have so
much more awareness now this is 1969 not
that i'm trying to bail him out i take
this very seriously
but um i did not grow up blaming him but
i i understand i because he really tried
his hardest raising us you know
and he had to learn to walk again after
the car accident with braces on his legs
so i admired him he tried really hard
and howard he felt so guilty he did i
think he lived with that when he woke up
in the hospital and they said you know
your wife has been killed and your baby
daughter katie and he was like and your
friend your niece he was like no no no
he sunk into the bed i mean he i think
he lived with that his whole life here's
the horror of life this is why i love
your book so much it was shocking to me
at the end and then it all made sense
when you say at the end down here you
were an older woman your dad was dying
of prostate cancer yeah
you put together that your dad might
have been a closeted gay man his whole
life
and this is the horror of our world
because these [ __ ] attacking gay
people even today and making gay bad
maybe that's why he was drinking and why
he was an alcoholic you hit the nail on
the head how did you figure out your dad
was gay i forget it was my last week of
saturday night live my very last show
such a big deal for me right he showed
her to my apartment by last week but he
was drunk when he showed up he had and i
was so bummed because he really hadn't
been drinking for a long time been had
sober for a few years you know so i was
like what
and um but understand he wasn't telling
me he had cancer he was keeping that
secret so he stopped at a bar at the
grand central station and met a college
boy a straight college boy and invited
that college guy back to my apartment
my little apartment in the west village
and so when i walked in the door after
rehearsals i s my dad was like molly
this is kevin you know he was like drunk
and i was like oh nice to meet you and i
was so mad because you know it kind of
makes you feel like you have to control
everything and i was just like
hey kevin how you doing like just a
total stranger like a fan
yeah in your apartment i just i kicked
him out i was like you got to go stand
hotel we were very close like normally
he would have stayed in my apartment
so he went and stayed in a hotel and
then i called my manager steven levy and
i was like i'm so mad at my dad you know
and stephen lost his dad when he was a
kid and stephen levy is gay and out and
stephen levy um really connected with my
dad uh they bonded like a he was like a
father figure to him so um steven in
that conversation when i complained
about my dad said
you're being too hard on him you're
being too hard on him you don't
understand he's given up so much for you
girls so much for you and mary and i was
like what are you he kept repeating i go
what are you saying are you saying he's
gay and he was like i don't want to tell
you he's going to tell you and i was
like oh my god i couldn't believe it so
understand i felt like ugh
so much compassion like kind of the
pieces of the story all coming together
like yeah that's why it's a good book
can you imagine what his life must have
been like i mean to be a closeted gay
man his entire life he probably drank
because he was in so much pain he was
under stress he took this job that was
in over his head
you know he kept he was probably
drinking more because he was stressed
out you know he's gay he's keeping that
inside i think he had tried to tell my
mom before that he said i saw this
psychiatrist and the psychiatrist told
me i'm a latent homosexual and she said
oh that psychiatrist never should have
told you that and so yes of course
you're gonna drink imagine if you
couldn't be who you were sexually it's
horrible
and isn't it amazing when you said to
your dad
like you said are you gay i asked him
one day at the four seasons we're
sitting by the pool i i invited him out
to um my press junket for serendipity
and i just was like we were having a
really good time and i was just like i'm
gonna ask him i'm gonna ask him cause
steven levy kept telling me he's gonna
tell you he's gonna tell you but then he
wasn't telling me so i just one day
asked him by the pool have have you ever
thought you might be gay and he just
said
most definitely and he was 72. and i was
like uh i felt he'd only said that when
he was younger but it's hard yeah it's
so hard